in 3 2 1 oh no everyone farted to the
microphone 3 2 way I'm cutting your head
off for that yeah I do me
it's random you randomly oh did it oh
your head game right off the glasses are
still there oh oh you're burning blood
yeah oh yeah it's so cool you like two
hairs on the back of your head the
glasses are still there yeah oh wait no
hang on oh you no no no no no no no no
wait getting all this stuff back I mean
my stuff
Wade you're such a dick all right here
we go waiting about me having yourself
life I can you can add I'm soil I do not
have a scrap mark hello everybody my
name is markiplier and I'm here with
Whedon Bob for more drunk my grass what
are you doing to that Panda I don't know
it's funny Paul why they didn't know is
it warm and toasty Oh God oh look I have
a war hammer
I like a goat how's the pork goat stop
it
stop killing everything you see I'll
kill you
not you Bob I'm talking to you Wow hey
littering Barbary parties are you
killing the innocent snake it was about
to kill me I'm gonna plant a snake head
grow snake truly violent yeah exactly
okay I planned a mistake that day I need
more booze welcome back everybody
oli made me drink this is not gonna be a
good episode for me I like when Molly
makes you drink it yeah oh oh oh I just
I came here because I'm I am an adult
Oh God I only ever clear this ball do
you even have ever cleared that's like
not over the house
Wow what whoa you can and shoot me shoot
how think I don't know
please shoot me shoot me please oh
please shoot me with your cannon it
really does look like your dick is
hanging
out of your pants oh please you're a
alright you gonna shoot me or well I
have no idea how to shoot it
you got to load it you got a prime it
stroke it a little bit and then you'll
load all the Cayman bank and see if it
loads it grab the cannonballs by both
hands and then undulate it a little bit
give it talk dirty to it I'm Archer
alligators over here what I don't care
about alligators I'm worried about Bob
shooting me in the face with his cannon
god I really want to shoot in the face
with my cannon please do am i ah could
you do it oh god no I won't lie to my
you hurt you hurt yourself far more than
you hurt me but I can't
I put cannonballs into the can whoa oh
hi buddy
Oh God anyway if we could make it
magically daytime right now that would
be lovely their instantaneous response
so I do wait welcome to what the hell is
this called again
minecraft know what [ __ ] you Wade was it
called
uh I'm craft Bob what is his cold dog
box 1.7.2 mod for technical why don't
you ask me I have no idea what this is
going Wow bye brah it's really strong
but probably not strong as yours Wade oh
this is uh I think I've got a P already
I'm gonna take a few sips a little Oh a
little okay so anyway we're here whoa
did that start moving oh yeah I did
oh okay Oh what the hell but either way
this is a new mod from the technic
launcher in our effort to explore
different avenues of drug minecraft
without constantly going back to
building a house over and over and never
succeeding wait wait no the house yes I
do
more than anything oh please let us
build a house all these magical maniacal
things let's fleet was that tower over
there else or the tower let's go take a
shower yeah okay this one right here to
do our house it's go windows in it it's
beautiful oh my god and is so affordable
right now mortgage rates have never been
lower
really so yeah more exaggerated
never bad his duck don't matter for no
booze Oh nah no one knows that like no
one knows I shouldn't even say that the
funniest part of that was lost forever
it is such a shame because you learnt
the shotgun wasn't the shotgun Mike
wasn't left in that camera had two
microphones and neither of them picked
up any audio we had to do that all over
again and it was funny the second time
it was but not that No Oh boss lumber
boss work sir where what are you talking
about I don't know what you I can't even
open this Oh every night I'm gonna die
ha ha ha
odds are there's a Botticelli dude a way
to kill him I had a soul okay I'm dead
all right knock back into you I like
this place very much it's uh not very
nice I don't even think I have power to
command is there a shark on the
staircase why is why okay I got diamond
armor apparently so I'm going back
yo why is there short-range Larry Smarr
mark mark wire why yes look at my petit
thankee thankee oh he's my pet oh wait
hell yeah you did it
alt maybe it was one of the admins Oh
was it me oh maybe it wasn't wait
it's like guardians of the galaxy who's
hidden spanky oh oh that's a fighter
I know I got it don't worry Spanky I got
your pay Spanky roll out there shooting
arrows from inside that's what's
happening they're hitting Spanky okay
well he Andy's healthier now yay goodies
Maggie good I'm in bed whoa what the
rare hunt hurt hunting Skell oh god oh
god oh god
whoa who the hell is happening
oh you're crazy early on in this episode
oh gosh
Wow Wow hey this is not cool
mark will die oh my you're hitting him
with an arrow I know I don't have
anything else I got a shark tooth that's
not even shovel you can have give it
give it give it give it give it give
give give give give give give you oh god
your your turn okay I don't know Bjorn I
don't have any armor is map date right
now hammer this is not okay there's a
sward in there can i okay I got I got I
got a diamond katana all boss God why'd
you wait ah oh come on Carly Kelly
killer killer killer killer killer kill
kill kill kill kill a kill is an anime
okay I'm getting out of here Oh how do
we you beat him oh he keeps healing what
do we do I'll kill I'm trying to kill ya
I yelled again Oh God
I don't think we could do enough damage
to this guy we've almost got it
no no no no we almost had him we almost
had one just chin him real hard ah
really hard okay ow
listen is it going on up under the bus I
got him
yeah goodies well I was good I uh we
don't have a sword or go Lise can I have
a sword you Nevada Lex oh god there's so
much like to the barb Oh what is it who
knew the Big E says isn't alcohol
lighter than water or is it more dense I
forget alcohol is more like water than
it is like not all right
okay I decapitated a skeleton now I got
hung up by the way I got a hat unlocked
Oh God I won't unlock what um ah the
whole thing about the thing falling down
this is that's right yeah I'm going
outside
come on leggy a braggy where's my tiny
box Tim we're dynamite oh okay that got
way too crazy right in the beginning of
that episode we need to tone it back a
little
oh we need to go build a house holy crap
house I liked it better when we just
built a house and called each other
douches the dicks Thomas now it's a lot
of action we build a little house that
way we'll be protected from whatever
monstrosity x' wants to try to kill us
oh so we just need to build a little
fortification you mean I don't have
anything I have a blunderbuss
what's that I don't have anything day
right it does this bug out
I missed hang on I miss you guys oh hey
I miss I miss there's a mini-map you got
so many arrows gonna hey are you legally
wait hang a hold still I'm gonna shoot
an apple off your head Wow damn mrs. Han
sorry yeah no no hold still wait oh oh
no no more no more no more where you
going we good we going oh oh you hidin
hiding I see your name tag Wade I see
your name J Oh where'd you go wait
where'd your name there go you probably
drunk a hole and is hiding here what the
hell is that
Oh God Oh what is that what is that whoa
Martha Zack it's like a slime frog Oh
God
slide come off of it as we attack oh
it's farted at us
Oh gross Oh zoo gross Wade get over here
and help you douche are you well yeah
we're not even able to build a house
because what do minute monsters I know
that's what we said catch Oh God
oh I got some more oh god oh god I
unlocked a helicopter hat oh wow
I'll try to kill you sighing slice
bastard I'm gonna clean up the signs
cloak is firing on the tracks line you
keep pressure on the Giant I'm gonna
help with the okay nevermind I'm going
for the biggest it's not going very well
this is insane Oasis both Tony it's 40
might him don't let it bother you
it's farting Oh God was this world of
warcraft
so gasps for me mark you got a tank oh
come on are we drowning there's a bar
over I know it's a boss watch art oh
there's a minute I'm dead okay thank you
wait hey just keep hitting it Dwight
well it's not come on wait I'm sorry
that's okay we did it yay always not
dead yet I got a new hat
Oh till you kill it it's healing it's
healing okay I killed it I killed it
you're welcome everybody I killed oh
yeah you get all the work you're welcome
you're welcome Wow you're welcome you
walk you're welcome you're welcome
everybody else's goddamnit can we tone
it back a little bit and build a house
yes I I don't know if that's gonna
happen in this mod mark just everybody
take a deep breath take a deep drink and
let's just remember we're here to have
fun
yeah Wow what keeps hitting me is that
Oh a little low a flying B thing we
don't care we don't care about the glowy
flying B there's trees over here we're
gonna build a house by the base of that
nice looking tower structure and then
we're gonna have a good time
wait why is it gonna be by the tower
though it doesn't seem like good idea
no noise I mean look at it it looks
pretty safe to me uh okay have I ever
led you astray have I ever made you look
I got a bread fish at I got a wait no
wait yeah look I got a bread with that
ah wait no how do i how do we get out of
this menu there we go look do I have a
hat on Bobby you still have no head you
still haven't known for you still have
no head either so do I have a hat on top
of my no head press H mark okay press
tej you see a hat thing yes ah hahaha
good anyways yeah I hat I can't I can't
the other one I love you how do I accept
changes are done okay I'd all right now
yeah there's my hat hello
oh I got the neon yeah yeah on coming at
me yeah I need okay
what mark Margot what are these what are
those
Oh God okay don't let him touch you oh
my god
come whitehill we need to build our
house so that we can be protected from
gathering wood I've got all the wood hey
guys got a big what I've got all the
wood will ever need yeah I won Here I am
wait there there you go
oh those are bricks oh how they're
eucalyptus their bricks okay start
building dammit god dammit make your
penis shut up no or not
oh god was that was that there oh god
what is that does a grasshopper
okay nothing big okay yeah here yeah can
we make a youkilis do a little bit buddy
Oh Calista --q shut up you're too drunk
you're drinking I need to drive yeah I'm
not finish this before the end of this
episode cool where's art I don't have a
voice I'm gonna make steps out here this
is gonna get you even bacon oh oh that
is not good
oh they get distinctly bad can you even
make steps and doors out of eucalyptus
plagues they're just normal steps and
doors I think oh yeah but it's different
because this is eucalyptus wood this
isn't regular wood Laver
the flavour of pure I can get you food I
forgot to give it to you thank you
oh my god wait you're the people enjoy
that wait I love you wait oh it's lungs
you gave me lungs yes I had Roger me
lung
I have muscle too boy we're not talking
about me yeah
what am I gonna do with lungs wait um I
am eating him oh my god they poisoned me
Oh awesome because they were a cookie
goddamn it
Bob you need to be more drug yeah you're
not little without one does anyone have
cobblestone yes no why would we have
that no we don't wait wait we don't wait
for the first time in the history of
drug viagra of you and I are teaming up
a chaos cuz bob is guys guys what close
the door close the door close the door
Bob you you have fun Bob have fun have
fun I can't
holy Helen yeah I can't his turn oh my
god literally terrifying
I imagine the worst friends ever I can
hit it from here it's not hitting me but
I can hit it I'm coming in no okay it's
running well god help okay no you're
fine you're fine you're fine Bob you're
fine Bob whatever okay so me and Wade
here succeeding in life well Bob this is
been weird
no no he's doing okay it's back but if
we build our house big enough we will be
able to worry about it yeah we don't we
have a thing to think about my weight my
best friend wade in the whole world
really yeah just just keep building up
yep keep building up I'm building the
roof now that's just gonna be the second
story then okay who tops you guys I
don't care okay all right well as soon
as our fortress is completed we'll be
impenetrable from all the mile I get
ready triple whoa it died who killed it
oh and chanted chest armor oh cool well
it's probably not better than my diamond
armor oh whatever
okay so yeah we built a castle fort
hey you know like whatever here's Roy we
built what penis it only a lot of
penises right you make it make it into a
penis is this pain we could I all right
a lot into a penis I'm just uh there's a
teddy in our house what is it Teddy
there's a teddy in our house wait behind
you is it Teddy or house all right kill
this whoa oh that was easy
Wow well then if I know they were that
yeah I'm gonna kill them house much less
to do
should have been time to go clear the
forest of these [ __ ] over here
whatever fine [ __ ] you get out of here
get out of here get out of here get out
of here get out of here
dad dad there are already this house is
gonna have a brown top from my
perspective why now I'm gonna be the
size of a brown child huh because I
don't have any more pink well that's
good I guess
wait how are we supposed to get to the
third storey we have a third story oh
wow we do know here yeah and I'll get it
I got enough wood what the hell I'm
interested no no I'll go back in I'm
gonna go back in that's what she said
behind you yeah what where Oh God oh hey
come here you bastards come here you Oh
God is it am I mistaken but this has
been the most insane episode of drug my
ground we've ever recorded
Oh God
Oh No okay what is it guys guys guys
guys I killed it let me alright I'll
leave him down there
let me out let me out laughs okay okay
we're gonna just left weed down there oh
yeah like you got us all right I think
our only option guys is to continue
building upwards oh by way Oh Bob Bob
you and I are now best right through
this I got golden apples Bob look I got
golden apples here how Wow yeah it's so
great up on our Tower oh man we're the
Bob you and I have always been best
friends and forever will be right Hey
look at that
we don't need wait I like I also like
how we each individually had to check
what everyone else was screaming about
and then in turn screamed and ran Oh
favorite wait you're never gonna make it
back up you're willing yeah well you're
just you're just screwed I mean you've
always been a pain in our side now that
we're uninhibited by your douchiness we
can continue on to be better people it's
just a fact I'm checking with arsenal
yeah back out oh wow all right Wade you
staying there yeah that's your that's
your punishment nope no it feels bad
doesn't it it feels bad that's a little
mean Phil looming okay Wade all right
Wade you're welcome back in the club
there's glowy fairies at the house Oh
Wade it's okay just calm down a little
bit when I'm here it's good in here okay
your your home Wade your you are home
yes welcome here now I got my gun so I'm
ready to offend us from whatever
monstrosity zs-- may appear
now from what we've seen this place is
horrifying but to be honest I think
we've seen the worst I'm not a mono city
right you're not a Monstress no Wade you
have a lovely top hat and I love you I
love you Wade
no not really but I mean just if it
makes you feel better just get away from
mom discards read hold that that is all
right al Oh oh god it was banshee
wowthat's or why that's not good well
then I'm here wake up you guys hide
hiding
gig guys get back okay wait no we should
go down to the other level and then open
up the window here so that we can see
okay so like I said we obviously have
weathered the worst of all the
monstrosity --zz that could possibly
befall us there's literally nothing else
to happen to us that would be wrong
Oh Oh what's happening what is that
we're not asking for trolling we're
asking for monsters ha ha what the what
Oh God oh I feel possessed oh god
there's goopy in my facade bye baby I'm
going downstairs by an invisible
phantasm oh my god isn't oh I killed it
I killed it I killed the phantasm I did
it I did it on the best good work thank
you mom I have a game play soul in my
inventory good for you we need to tone
it back a little bit because this has
gotten insane and I really miss the you
know origins of drunk minecraft of just
having a good time yeah here isn't
really that what having some fo my god
whoa I'm coming Bob I'll save you Oh
limp get out of here that's great
gross Oh oh no I I I killed it Bob I
killed that up I killed it after you
don't know very very much there's
berries I don't hear about the fairies
okay
oh I don't care hey though I know
there's teddy bears way just whatever
just whatever okay so we're just gonna
calm down a second because we need to
get back to the car with Drake boys you
guys freak out too much you guys go to
crazies you see this dial aback I don't
think I go to deep breath I think I
appropriate responses I don't know Bob
you you freaked out alone drink you know
guys that drink has gotten better I'm
gonna say I'm almost done with my drink
this is a 32 ounce bottle that probably
had about it I usually like that but now
it's a good drink yeah I don't even want
to know how many I don't know when I
press that was bad she poured even more
alcohol in but now it's now it's special
yeah oh really making this the top I
think I poured lol anyway so I think
we've beaten this game I think we've
reached the end there we literally no
other no yeah we won we won it in this
mug we win we win in every version of
Minecraft but this one we won more than
anything because just look at us we're
like sexy [ __ ] over handsome and
we're awesome and we're just bad that's
like pletely not even conspicious I'm
gonna make this very phallic so yes yes
right like comment and subscribe if you
think we are sexy [ __ ]
eNOS gonna get your life you want more
penis drawings of us so draw a fan art
with our penises in it why not uh okay
maybe not that if I do that yeah let's
I'll do that Bob in a maid's outfit with
matching snout nipples it's totally fine
that's exactly fine yeah but this is a
family friendly show so wait why the
hell you talk about penis is that all
those are not building 100 don't know if
the penis going into the house yes I
think it is oh god wait that is quite
good thing there's quite the girl and
wait the guy
each night I get in it and watch out
I'm a genius Nega the Tina's TNT is
everyone what I promised God's wait
what's that up in the sky is there
something in the sky
oh no there's nothing at this guy
give me inventory full of something to
build up there's more things in this guy
really fancy clouds screw you there's
things the sky make Godzilla so I didn't
lady
oh you admins are you admins is you
sitting around don't know what to do cuz
I mean I my legs being shake this
happens as penises and stuff every
episode we have penises in it I don't
know what you're talking about I should
go by I just have a single best request
that's ever come out of the show what
did I got me there's something the sky
give me something to get up in the sky
make Godzilla destroy everything I fell
Haram Dobby do something god you haven't
taken everyone all these achill I don't
see a Godzilla here are you dusting bark
cats ye okay oh hey I have an idea
here we go
I gotta have a [ __ ]
join divorce
ah